Let's go over a little more detail about Operant Conditioning, before I send
you over to Susan for a wrap-up on this section in the lesson. So when the
consequences of our behavior result in something being added to the
environment. To increase the likelihood of the behavior occurring again in the
future. This is called a positive reinforcement because we're adding something
to the environment. On the other hand, when the consequences of our behavior
result in something being removed from the environment to increase the
likelihood of the behavior occurring in the future. This is a negative
reinforcement. Because something is being removed from the environment. Now
it's important to note here, that both of these are reinforcements, and
reinforcements increase the likelihood of a behavior. So even though here,
something is added. And here something is removed. They both increase a
likelihood of a behavior, but do so using different mechanisms. Now I'll send
you back to Susan to finish up this section on operant conditioning. Before we
move on to social learning.